what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john how's it
going good i'm excited to go back to the
world of tolkien middle earth guys we
got ourselves the lord of the rings the
rings of power two episodes
each episode budgeted at around 400
million dollars this show cost
1.9 billion dollars to put together
that's all anyone cares about i'm
excited for it i know that upsets some
people i don't care i'm excited for it i
love the lord of the rings and i enjoy
parts of the hobbit uh so guys
leave a like subscribe and click that
notification bell to notify my reaction
for the next lord of the rings episode
is up here on the channel oh as always
full-length throughout your watch along
where you sync up with your own copy are
available at our patreon for super sexy
rejects cover bunch of shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch long's included and the team at
prepper
good luck
[Music]
it's not going to float
it's going
to sail
so it's a metaphor for for her and her
journeys dude
boats woke
[Music]
oh you dicks elves aren't supposed to
act like this
do you know why
a ship floats
and a stone cannot her case is not
downward but up fixed upon the light
that guides her
how am i to know which lights to follow
you're asking too many questions
but that seems so simple
the most important truths often are
but you must learn to discern them for
yourself i won't always be here to speak
them to you
are you foreshadowing
[Music]
production budget
one filled with untold perils
and strange creatures beyond cult
a place known
as middle earth yeah
wow
cool
where eagles dare not fly
they said it would be over quickly
but the war
left middle earth
in ruin god damn
for his orcs had spread
to every corner of middle earth
those eyes multiplying ever greater
under the command of his most devoted
servant
a cruel
and cunning sorcerer
my brother vowed to seek him out and
destroy him
but sauron found him first
and marked his flesh with a symbol
sauron's like steppenwolf yep got it in
the darkness
his vow
became mine
this time it's personal more and more of
our kind
began to believe that sir
was but a memory
and the threat
at last
was ended
huh
but not me
i wish i could be one of them
nice
i'm digging this it's been years since
the last orc was cited
how long can living flesh india where
even sunlight fears to tread
perhaps we would be wise to camp here
and tomorrow begin the journey home
they just climbed all that
let's go right back down again
[Music]
wait no
we keep moving
you're being stubborn galadriel
these are the only people who believe in
you
[Music]
save the cat
i like her now i like her she was she
was kind of a hard ass before but yeah
but now i like she's got a softer son
[Music]
oh no
oh cool
jesus
this is where the orcs gathered after
morgoth's defeat
this place is so evil our torches give
off no walks
dang
this is a really good looking
yeah
it really is
man
the door was filled in here
damn that doesn't hurt your fist she
have super strength
maybe maybe her hand is too afraid to
feel for how evil this place is
even stone cannot hide the mark of one
whose very hand is flame unquenched
he was here
i feel like i'm watching a really cool
video game
[Music]
troll hunter
oh my god
these guys work so hard to get here
oh
that's just not fair
oh nice
oh yes
the order is given
we march at first light
oh newton
right here this is the place to do it
then you shall do so alone
we've encountered a lot
but not a snow troll
look like a badger maybe a fox more
likely a half foot don't care to be seen
none but if you do
watch yourself
dangerous creatures they are
[Laughter]
he's messing with you
[Music]
clear and clear
[Music]
oh damn so they're like wilder people
[Music]
got a whole society oh
[ __ ] it's ready to pack up and hide at
any minute
there's 110 things out here that could
kill us 100 11 if we count you worrying
to death
111 easter egg bilbo's birthday
11 today
beautiful
[Music]
oh god
you guys always make me so hungry
just a dog you know how dogs love
parries
or is it a warg
i'm pretty sure they'll introduce new
creatures john
no just the same
view
wargs orcs and balrogs
crag and crevice washing away the lost
remnants of our enemy
like a spring rain over the bones of a
dead animal
harold
that's elrond harold elrond
he had a first name i guess
your friend has arrived
she's here
oh my god he used to be filled with
wonder
before he was
poetic beaten down by the
second age
you have only just arrived
must you speak of leaving again so soon
you know very well where i must
we must keep the plot going
test him again
you may find him less receptive than you
might have hoped
are you going to arrange an audience or
not
i can't believe they got neil patrick
harris to play all wrong
spitting image of hugo weaving
haven't you ever wondered
what else is out there
how far the river flows or were the
sparrows learn the new songs they sing
in spring you started the [ __ ]
it's all your fault
they returned to us
in triumph
for they have proven beyond any doubt
that our days of war
are over
yes
and nothing will change that
our days of peace
begin
[Music]
so get that stick out of your ass
galadrie
our days of peace begin right
and granted passage across the sea to
dwell for all eternity
the undying lands of valinor
at last
they are going home
valhalla
your mystery sigil
i shared it with the high king then why
would it because seeing a sigil does not
mean you're any closer to finding sauron
it is over
the evil is gone then why is it not gone
from in here cause you haven't got a
therapy yet yeah you got trauma sister
evil does not sleep around
it waits
and in the moment of our complacency
it blinds us
permits
no one in history has ever refused the
call
you say i have one victory over all the
horrors of middle earth
yet you would leave them alive in me
to take with me
god so much darkness in her eyes
put up your sword
without it what might be
what you have always been
you will be a queen
powerful beyond all the measure
so elrond for the longest time just
dealt with women who don't listen to him
his whole life
whole life trying to give advice in the
woods and they just don't take it
[Music]
grunge i like how they play like upper
trauma as if like you're crazy but we
know she's not crazy
and that pain isn't what gives her the
intuition
is in three moves
[Laughter]
really been a fortnight already oh so
there's clearly banging
[Laughter]
tension
if it'll pass through a few days back
said his grazing's gone rotten no only
weeds will grow where was he from uh
didn't say east i think
and what day was it here oh let it go
knife is
oh
our true king will return
and priors right out from under your
pointy boots easy lot quench the fire
i like him
such a badass anything to report
nothing out of the ordinary
and the well
how was it
did you draw some water
the high king has declared the days of
war are over
all the far outposts are being disbanded
we're leaving
destroy your bow at once his whole
identity based off that and he doesn't
have an excuse to visit his woman now i
know
poor guy
elf
they're not human but for 79 years
you've kept watch over the men and women
of tiharat not because of what their
ancestors once did
but because of who they still are
and be grateful
but you need never see them again are
they the ones who are also of elvish
descent
i believe people in the village correct
us if we're wrong but i think that's the
case
say what you wish to say
i have said it already
100 times over
in every way but words
mother
there's a man here for you god damn it
boy a man and not an elf
you could just give her a look
she's got some sort of a
sickness
what manner of sickness
put it down if it's
misery she been grazing
she wanted east a few days ago
i think she might have met something
no oh no
how far east
she might have made it as far as horton
oh the war's still on
where are you going hold on today's
journey believe now i can reach it by
dusk i'm going with you you're gonna
tell that okay you watch the house son
stay with this man with the cow
and uh
squeeze out a little more of that black
milk maybe that's why your father run
off like he's done my father didn't run
off then what happened to him
salty rascal's got the king's bounty
down there
this is the real bounty
the quicker picker-upper
oh
[Music]
oh it's got the mark on it
oh no
well the same wind that seeks to blow
out a fire may also cause its spread oh
interesting what you did was right
for galadriel
and for middle earth
it's hard to see what is right
when friendship and duty are mingled
yeah
don't worry i'll be taking that long
voyage soon enough are you acquainted
with the work of lord
keller brimbour
the greatest of elven smiths of course
i've admired his artistry since i was a
child
especially his rings first the big
people
now the stars
eyes open when they should be sleeping
[Laughter]
this lap
it's got like a reverse aragorn and
irwin thing with them
[Music]
yeah
now the evil's gone
evil's gone
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful
[Music]
that is gorgeous and kind of haunting oh
my god
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
how am i to know which rice to
follow sometimes we cannot know
until we have touched the darkness
huh
[Music]
oh
what
nice cut
how the hell is she gonna get back to
land
do they know in there who's supposed to
be arriving no seriously how's she gonna
get back to land
swim a lot or ride a shark or hitch a
ride on some kind of mythical beast yeah
sign
yeah
the evil's gone
[Music]
it's like found a ufo
meteor crash
who is that
[Music]
modesty glow
wow
[Laughter]
i don't
think so i'm gonna go on a limb here and
say probably not
huh but you never know
i mean it's just like it's a big ring of
fire yeah i mean it's definitely
supposed to invoke the eye
yeah and just the general you know lava
oriented quality that mount doom has
mordor has well what'd you think that
was quite striking and quite sweeping i
mean it's a lot a lot a lot of place
setting and you know getting to kind of
meet everybody but i was very engrossed
in all the different places we went it
feels novel-esque in the way that like
yeah there are some action scenes there
are some like thrilling moments but it's
not
just trying to get to that stuff you
know
um
yeah so far so good what did you think
it's good it's good
i wouldn't say i love it i think there's
a reason they released two episodes so i
don't think there's a point in talking
forever yeah sure because like yeah i
mean obviously visuals look awesome
um yeah production values are insane of
course they should there's one thing
this
this should get right
it's look good but yeah this is so
expensive with all the money you've
thrown at it you better
and beyond in terms of yeah sets and cg
effects and costuming and all that stuff
and i mean i think that quality is very
locked in that was the one thing i never
had any worries about i heard there was
like 20 plus series regulars on on this
show i do think that even for a first
episode it is a little bit affected by
it because there wasn't anyone
at least for my taste my viewing it's
not like i don't care about anyone it's
that i'm not i don't find myself that
emotionally drawn or emotionally
attached to anyone yeah because there's
it's so much there's so much they have
to set up there's so much they have to
establish and re-establish
mainly newly established and also help
distinguish due to the fact that there's
just so much going on and there's so
much people and to meet
that it also becomes very expositional
heavy yeah and then you know explain the
back story explain this explain this you
don't really get time to like just kind
of
hang out with the characters
you know it's like aladrill's one note
is i want revenge i want revenge and
everyone's kind of annoying because
nobody believes me yeah i want revenge
but i am true of heart and and then you
have the
i'm forgetting his name the the elf
yeah and uh the girl in the village to
me that's the one that's the easiest to
connect to because it's it's a it's a
tale that's been told yeah it's been
tails been told a gazillion times uh but
i thought it was effective like that was
the one i was most uh drawn to you know
so a lot of this is
about being caught up in the emotions of
pretty much what the imagery
and the music and the set pieces
and what whatever emotions generate from
experiencing that
is where it comes from because yeah i
mean if you're gonna be out this is
gonna be like a five season show or some
[ __ ] yeah so if it's gonna be that long
you know i imagine there's a lot to set
up and a lot of world building but i
don't want to just be a work i feel like
it starts to become like an you know i
don't want to watch an essay
and i feel like there's a reason they
released two yeah so i'm not gonna say
this is the show it was really pulling
at me in in in the last like 10 to 15
minutes of of this hour-long episode
so yeah i like like the last the first
15 minutes a lot and the last 15 minutes
or like yeah last like 10 i would say i
always enjoyed it but i never really
found it that compelling
so
yeah i mean it's definitely something
that i was engrossed more in moments
than
the whole flow of the episode and it is
a bit daunting because you are like okay
you know if if you're not an expert on
the second age there's a lot you got to
make sure that you catch and that you
you know distinguish and and you know
there's that game of uh you know not to
i know lord of the rings predates game
of thrones but on tv you know i feel
like there is that sort of uh pressure
to deliver on yeah that that like
really distinct ensemble of realms and
the really fleshed-out world and it's
funny because you think about the movies
and you're like okay it's three movies
nine-ish hours but even still like the
first installment you do get in a more
compact package
time it feels like to just live with and
be with the life of you know your
different characters whether it be the
hobbits or whoever and here there are
moments like that but yeah it's a lot of
place setting it's a lot of figuring out
okay what is the world of the harfords
like right now and how are they affected
by the overall situation and then the
elves and then there's the king the
realms of men we don't really get that
much dwarf action in this episode but
yeah lots of place setting lots of setup
well it's also a lot of like stoic way
of speaking everyone's pretty silly
which makes sense to me based off of the
characters you're primarily following
like you're following the har foots like
okay
pre-hobbit so they
make sense why they have more
personality infused within them whereas
the other ones are a lot more poetic and
and the elegance
of them so actually i i like galadriel
you know as for for a main character i
don't know the actress who's playing her
i like how
this sounds weird
i like how
traumatized she is like she carries that
trauma in her eyes there's this constant
like
there's this constant like wide-eyed
paranoia pain
that is in her presence she's so
sometimes sincere in her pursuit of this
and it doesn't feel like it comes from a
place of ego like i need to be right
yeah it feels like no this is
i know intimately the horror of this
situation and i can't rest until it is
stopped and i think what's cool about
the connective tissue of when you think
about that scene actually in lord of the
rings when
frodo is tempting her with the ring
and then she does her whole like big
speech and she becomes all like witchy
gothic like yeah every queen in the
darkness and all that you're a dark lord
and then you're seeing that oh yeah no
there's a there is a lot of darkness
within her and i think they had a good
they did a great job in the beginning
especially
with contrasting that of really just
you're plucked into you're like dropped
into her world
how beautiful and sunshiny and
glimmering it is
and then the morgoth character the dark
side of the song of
uh yeah with the morgoth and seeing how
their world was like i actually really
felt that which which i think they do a
little stronger
here than they do in the movies because
i love that prologue in the opening
narration and like fellowship of the
ring
i even enjoy the one in the hobbit but
those start off like in the darkness
yeah and then here you gotta really feel
the effect of the darkness because they
thrust you first into like look how
look how ideal it
basically yeah this is
so good everything we got going even the
bullies yeah whatever we got a couple of
like bullies but that's just for the
board little white kids we're fine we're
fine yeah there's good stuff that's good
we got a good thing going in general
this is a lush beautiful place and we
are a harmonious people yeah yeah and
then yeah you feel the real harsh grit
when the things that are more familiar
the dark aspects set back in and reality
hits
and then that adds to the whole tension
of like nobody knows what's coming yeah
it's true i feel like there's a lot more
to unpack and a lot more to set up still
like something like yeah we're set up
don't they yeah so let's start a solid
start yeah but there's we gotta still
meet the whole dwarf situation yes true
oh yeah you gotta meet the dwarves too i
mean
but beyond that like what we currently
got here i'm already immediately finding
myself just kind of craving some just
real conversations
yeah
with two people just kind of talking to
each other for a little bit you want two
characters to lay down like the
pretenses because that is a thing and
it's you know it's i won't begrudge them
just yet but yeah when when the elf guy
shows up and he's in the village
especially and even when he's talking to
his love
they're both like just so serious and
stoic and it's all like the most
important you know like it would be nice
to see
and the hobbits or the har foot her foot
being one of the types of hobbits they
they
bring that life through them but it
would be nice to see some of the other
characters like be more at ease as they
communicate and speak yeah because yeah
i think that's something that dogs the
hobbit movies even is like there are
certain characters with whom you only
get the stoic
you know burdened by duty kind of
approach and that can hold you at an
arm's length from characters sometimes
not that it's not cool to have that
mystique but yeah you got to balance it
out
yeah i mean
like not that the only way to get to
know characters is through
is through dialogue you get to know
characters through their actions as well
i was finding some of that like when
you're going past the monologue the the
prologue and then you're in the
the top of the uh the ice mountains and
stuff
it was kind of moving a little quick i
think we just i need a little bit more
time with it uh for it to settle in if
you're book readers of
this isn't
like i don't know it's based after that
what was the book
the summer really is this is after that
yeah because that's mostly like first
aid stuff and then the second age was
filled in i think by tolkien's son to a
degree and and those books like the
salmorelli and a lot of the other
writings from from my vague
understanding is that they don't play
they're not written like
stories the same way lord of the rings
of the habitar where it's like oh
characters interacting they're more
history books and in a way
i appreciate like i'm curious to hear
what the lord of the rings fans have to
say once they actually see the show and
everybody stops freaking out about the
trailers uh because there's a quality of
this that i do kind of associate with
the reading experience of the actual
lord of the rings which is like there is
a sort of like historical like there are
characters to love and get attached to
but it's not the most
forward about those kinds of things and
so having this
intro here through the show it feels
akin to the
the sensibilities of the books in that
way but at the same time yeah i i feel
like for a show you need to bridge that
gap and give us these moments of
humanity that you might not have seen
the same way in the book
yeah i i i i am sick of that excuse of
it's
it's like in the comics so it was in the
comics it's how it is in the books i'm
like doesn't mean it
makes for
truly entertaining visual medium
and so
i'm curious i'm here yeah i'm curious if
that's what some people want
and not to say that that's like right or
wrong but yeah you're correct it's like
how do you split that difference while
honoring that but also bringing us a
little closer you know to your to the
emotional cores of the character yeah
yeah yeah because
i feel like if you're gonna go slow
moving in your first episode
then
you should uh not just primarily only do
world building it shouldn't feel like a
lecture that you have to take you should
get really invested in the characters
yeah first and foremost before you go
but then again i don't know in fact some
in some ways this this first experience
kind of reminds me of the witcher sure
of of when i was like man i don't want
to wrap my head around
yeah jesus christ
and then it was like the third episode
where i was like oh damn the show's
getting great yeah it's like oh i love
this show yeah yeah and i could see it
being a very similar experience
man there's a lot of people there's a
lot of world here
a lot of things yeah i think they
actually have a map for you to look at
once in a while yes there's a lot for
you to keep up with
and and then once we can get that all
out of the way then you can go all right
it's good because yeah everything on a
technical standpoint is good i think
every actor here has given that is doing
a great job i think everyone's doing a
really great job i think all the
performances are good i think everything
on a technical standpoint is solid the
music is phenomenal the visuals are
about as
phenomenal as you'd expect when you hear
60 million dollars per episode like yeah
they better be amazing and i think
they're great yeah now it's just about
now i need to really give a [ __ ] about
the characters yeah you know yeah cause
right now everyone's just like yeah
they're cool yeah
everyone's like they're cool
and there's i gotta to make sure i
remember them all they're gonna keep
track of them i bet you know you kind of
do hope that they would strike lightning
in a bottle with at least one or two
characters that you're like
off the bat off the bat love them yeah i
can't wait to see more yeah yeah yeah
and the only one who really who who got
me close to feeling that way was the
uh god what is his name the the black
elf yeah yeah i'm just
trying to just call him that
he was the closest one who who like
within a scene was like i like this guy
he's cool i feel like a lot of history
with him and then like that's an example
of learning about a character through
actions i think totally and you can feel
the the greater context of this guy's
story but you can also feel the direct
personal here and now stakes of his
story yeah at least in a way that feels
kind of well-rounded
yeah at the outset i think where i'm at
with collateral right now is i'm at a
point of like i'm understanding now i'm
understanding galadriel better and
understanding her backstory better yeah
but it but it was so uh
like the plot heaviness of
saurons out there we got if i'm like
we just i feel like i watched like a
bunch of hours of this
except less certainty now
just like other characters worried about
sauron yeah well that's a pitfall that i
think this kind of like these kinds of
fantasy
stories these epics can fall into is is
the character was being so purpose
driven to the point that that's kind of
it
and and not that i again begrudge her
the the purpose that she has or anything
like that but yeah it seems like okay
this is most of your character right now
is just all about this
and uh it would nice to it would be nice
to see the rounding and
some
it's maybe some of the internal conflict
in in the sense of like
she must
this doesn't seem like she has any level
of doubt but it would be interesting to
maybe have some doubt in there or some
kind of
you know she seems to have like a close
relationship with elrond they seem very
familial
even that like she is so assured which
is fine which could grow into a good
character trait you know as we see more
but at the same time yeah it can make it
a one-track mind character it's like
this is what took away from tauren
oakenshield so much for me in the hobbit
movies is like
this guy kind of only thinks and talks
about this whereas
like in the book that's his purpose
that's his mission but like he's a
character as well as that and i feel
like that's a thing that that
media like this often has to transcend
especially in the visual media
because it is easy to just be like
brooding purpose-driven badass and
that's it you know well i think in a
book too you can also be especially if
it's not uh like like lord of the rings
it's not a first person
uh perspective so you can occasionally
just
write a few lines about what they're
thinking and feeling internally to to
clue you in word this relies on the body
language of the actor which is why why
i'm crediting the actors a lot because i
think they really brought their a game
here
and i felt like the actress who plays
collagera was really
really trying to show all that even
though she was kind of given a bunch of
re repetitive scenes yeah but i did like
the scene when she was debating with l
ron i thought that was good like i think
that context was was the best
uh that emotionally clicked with me
because yeah i don't know i don't set up
to i've been i'm i've been rooting for
this show i so want this to be i want to
be great i want this to be great i
wanted this to shut up every week
i want it to be great so i'm not here to
try to like
put pick things apart and you know even
though we've talked for longer than i
would have liked to
um there is a reason to release two
episodes yeah so decent solid start and
i'll take that
i'll take that as compared to what it
could have been you know but yeah let's
let's build on this
i don't know man when you say 60 million
dollars an episode i'm like your first
episode better rock my [ __ ] socks
well that's what it may be it does for
most people that's the thing it's like i
i gladly acknowledge that i am i could
very well not be the voice of many well
that's the thing is i hear 60 million
dollars an episode i'm like you know
that a lot of that money did not go to
the script so i feel like that's been
the whole thing the entire time for me
is like the scripts have to be great
because i know they can make it look
like it costs 60 million dollars
which they do but that means nothing to
me like
even for me that sheen
wore off like 20 minutes in i'm like it
looks it looked great throughout and
then there was a couple of moments like
well it was really good but then after a
while it was like
all right i'm used to this
i did i i've accepted the fact that you
look phenomenal
yeah yeah yeah yeah i've gotten used to
how incredible you look and now i need
to hear more about your personality yeah
i did i did really like the ending bit
on the ship that was really well done
yeah that was really weird especially
having you know alluded to and seen you
know glimpses of people traveling to
that to the
the name of the realm escapes me here in
this moment but yeah traveling into that
sort of uh into the east to the elven
you know after life land essentially
feels so ominous and like i don't know
if i want to go there
like is this a good thing or are they
being fed to some kind of primordial
creature but yeah that whole thing of of
the ceremony and the maidens like taking
off their armor and really making this
visual transition and then them being
like swallowed into this light i thought
that was like
that was one of those moments where like
i was like wow i i didn't even think
about how you would go about depicting
this but this is pretty beautiful so
yeah
but yeah agreed agreed gotta gotta get
those character bits going
yeah no i think the i said the first
like 10 to 15 in the last 10 were
really solid
and everything in between was good it
was fine it was pretty good yeah
yeah um all right guys well we gotta
watch the next episode so we'll see
we'll see what opinions change
[Music]